all right shell podcast Sean told me
that I should probably do a disclaimer
at the beginning of this episode because
today we were talking about minimalist
diets we brought in a vegan a carnivore
and an omnivore medical doctor to talk
about those diets but I am NOT a doctor
so please do not take any of the
information you're about to hear as
medical advice but I do hope you really
enjoyed this episode about minimalist
diets and minimus hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn Ryan Nicodemus is
out on assignment today he's taking care
of his grandma all down in Florida so
I've got some special guests in the
studio with me today today we're gonna
talk about simple diets we're gonna talk
about optimal health we're gonna talk
about strategies for healing we're gonna
talk about the gut microbiome we're
gonna talk about all my health problems
and we're gonna talk what we're gonna
answer your questions with today's guest
some of my favorite people in the world
and some new favorite people to me as
well we have a plant-based athlete here
my good friend rich roll is here thank
you for being here today rich it's so
good to be here
you can find him on the rich roll
podcast of rich roll com we have dr.
Paul Saladino from his podcast the
fundamental health podcast you can find
him at Paul Saladino MD com thank you
for being here today it's great to be
here thanks for having me and we have
dr. tell me would one of the smartest
human beings on the planet Earth well at
least of the smartest human beings that
I know he's from nourish balance thrive
calm he is one of the doctors one of the
many doctors have been helping me with
with many of my health woes with testing
and supplements and anti microbials and
and a whole litany of well we've gone
down the rabbit hole and we'll go down
the rabbit hole a bit more today you can
find him at nourish balanced thrive calm
and also the nourish balanced thrive
podcast
all right gentlemen we're gonna have a
conversation today not a debate and I
find that the quickest way for us to
have a conversation and get into your
stories is for us to tackle some
listener questions our first question
today is from Anna in Amsterdam what
reliable resources would you recommend I
could read to get
in form in terms of vegan carnivorous
and um [ __ ] diets well it's a fairly
expansive question here because she's
looking for some resources I'm sure we
can get to that but basically I am here
with a vegan a carnivore and an omnivore
and I don't know what I am anymore
sounds like this thoughts are a really
bad joke so here's the thing though I
the three of you thrive on three I don't
say radically different diets but
certainly three different philosophies
ideologies and so I think it's a good
place to start what led each of you to
well to the diet or lifestyle you're on
let's start with rich well I've been
eating plant-based for about twelve
years at this point I'm 52 when I was 40
I was about 50 pounds overweight and I
was subsisting on basically the standard
American diet leaning towards a lot of
fast food a lot of takeout a lot of lack
of self-care and I had a bit of a health
scare
late one evening heart disease runs in
my family and that compelled me to take
stock of how I was living and that kind
of catalyzed me into a search for how to
better take care of myself that kind of
culminated or led me into the
plant-based lifestyle which really
rejuvenated me revitalized me got me
interested in fitness and kind of
restored my vitality and it's been kind
of a progressive evolution ever since
dr. Paul Saladino you you it's funny I
see a lot of people and Tommy you can
probably attest to this as well a lot of
the times when I see people move toward
a carnivorous diet it's because they
have a lot of problems whether it's
autoimmune issues it digestion or gut
microbiome issues but I don't think that
was the case with you what led you to to
exploring this this diet this lifestyle
so this my my journey to nose-to-tail
carnivore diet really began 10 to 15
years ago at the beginning of my medical
career
I was a physician assistant I practiced
in cardiology before I went back to
medical school and you know I've I think
that I came at this from the position of
a physician who's really quite
interested perhaps obsessed with
understanding the roots of chronic
disease and really throughout my
training had disappointment after
disappointment it was just a process of
continually losing my religion and being
told that things would help patients but
then not seeing them help patients
whether those are pharmaceutical drugs
or different ways of eating that didn't
actually fix things that people were
having wrong with them and so I think
that throughout my medical journey I've
just become more and more interested in
understanding what actually was at the
root of illness mostly autoimmune is
what I'm most interested in and I think
that you can make it pretty seem to be
an argument that most chronic disease is
inflammatory in an autoimmune in nature
but I've been so focused on
understanding what was at the beginning
of that and how those were getting
started and that's really led to my sort
of gradual progression and discovery and
sort of well just examination of
different ways of eating thinking that
food is probably at the root of what
causes illness or wellness for some
people and many years ago I I did a raw
vegan diet for eight months and
experienced that and I personally didn't
have great experiences with that I lost
25 pounds of muscle and then had some
health issues and then kind of tried
paleo an autoimmune Paleo and then
throughout my medical career was
thinking you know like how am I gonna
help these people because you know I'm
in psychiatry and practice functional
medicine and it's so hard to have people
come to me who aren't getting better and
not really wait on me and so when I
discovered animal-based diets and the
idea of a carnivore diet at first I
thought that's kind of wild but the more
I looked into it it's been pretty
eye-opening to see the way that for a
large number of people know the
exclusion of all the plant products has
led to great improvements in health from
an inflammatory and autoimmune nature
yourself to yeah yeah I've been strictly
carnivore for about eight and a half
months now so no plants and eight and a
half months I know I offered you some
coffee this morning you're like now I
can't even have coffee and so we'll talk
about that because Tommy is drinking
some coffee and you know it's
fascinating I've talked a lot to Tommy
over the last several
years and I know there are times you've
told me you know that where you look at
a case-by-case basis and sometimes a
vegan diet is the most appropriate diet
for someone or removing all fiber from
someone's diet is the most appropriate
thing for for helping them heal so when
we when we look at this I guess more
holistically you you're the omnivore of
the group as am i I mean I just eat
what's in front of me and what tell me
tells me to eat at this point so so talk
to me about about how do we how do we
look at both approaches and how do we
decide when when either is applicable so
that's that's a really good question and
what I spend quite a bit of my time
doing working with people either with
chronic disease or people who were
trying to perform maximally in some
sports work in multiple sports there's
so many things yet to take into account
and one thing that I noticed from Anna's
question is she wants information in
terms of how she can eat better in line
with her values but I don't know what
her values are yes so it makes it very
difficult to know where we're trying to
come from from a value perspective so
that's something that she'll obviously
have to to use to interpret the answers
that people are giving but in terms of
the the question that you asked often
you might start with a given set of
values so I know so I listen to Annie my
delgado on your podcast recently I was
speaking to knee to Annie my because we
have a client in common and so you know
one of the main things if somebody comes
and says this is the way that I want to
eat how do I get the best out of it and
that's you know that's one approach to
take another scenario where plant-based
diets or you know particular fad
plant-based diets have been successful
is when somebody has a particular type
of gut issue and I often think it's
endotoxin related and one of the ways
that endotoxins get into the blood and
if i'm getting too technical for let me
know from morons like me explain where
endotoxins are so any toxins quite
simply are toxins that are in the wall
of certain types of bacteria and they
are in your guts in
more or less proportion and a
concentrated fat is a really good way to
get them into your bloodstream and they
cause havoc and inflammation so I study
brain injury and one of the ways that I
simulate brain injury is by giving
endotoxin that's one of the best ways to
do it and then that's one scenario where
you can really get a dramatic reduction
in symptoms however on the other side
there are some people who just for
whatever reason can't digest fibers or
there are certain aspects of plants that
they really don't react well to this has
to be like these these people in both
cases you're given there have some sort
of compromised gut microbiome can you
can you explain first off give us a
high-level view what what for someone
doesn't know what the gut microbiome is
how would you explain that to someone
it's basically the bugs that live in
your gut and the microbiome actually
describes the genes of the bugs that
live in your guts whereas the the bugs
themselves are the microbiota they were
used interchangeably nowadays and yes
that's probably a big part of it whether
that stems from the diet so I think one
thing that I'd love to hear both of
these guys talk about is what they can
agree on in terms of maybe what humans
shouldn't be eating because I think
there's a lot of agreement potentially
there in terms of what these guys don't
eat and that's where a lot of the
problem comes from yeah I think we can
start by saying we all agree that
whether it's vegan or a vegan diet or
carnivorous diet
there are non-ideal versions of these
right there there's the the Oreo based
diet which is yeah to be sure I mean I
would say straight up that there's a
difference between a whole food
plant-based diet and a vegan diet a
vegan diet you know especially these
days with the preponderance of you know
amazingly delicious non animal product
derivative type foods you can be very
unhealthy on a vegan diet but you can
just I would just say right right away
in terms of delicious diets if I have to
pick between these two vegan diet wins
by far right but yeah so I think to
conflate whole food plant-based with
vegan can be confusing and I think to
your question about what we can
certainly all agree on here
I think is that processed foods are no
bueno and in our day and age when you go
to the grocery store almost every single
aisle proliferate swith process to
ultra-processed foods it's only when you
go to the very far side on the aisle
that you actually get real food and I
think there's something wrong with that
equation that that we really need to
look at and address yeah so where we
agree is processed foods bad right but
there are also terrible versions of a
carnivorous diet right you often see
people like well I'm just gonna eat
charred brisket three times a day it's
probably not the most ideal in terms of
nutrient density I would totally agree
with that I think that there are you
know it's funny I think in the carnival
world we sort of adopted the same sort
of terminology maybe a hat tip to the
vegans on this one whole foods
animal-based diet you know it's like
Whole Foods plant-based Whole Foods
animal-based but I think that you're
using the term nose-to-tail no sale yeah
so I think that you know we'll probably
talk about this at some point but I
think that much of the data or some of
the data that looks shady for me it is
often confounded by inclusion of
processed meats and things like this we
know that added nitrates are not a good
thing for people to be eating and yeah I
would agree that processed meats and you
know sort of junk food animal based
products are not a good thing for people
be eating in general but when I think of
nose-to-tail I'm thinking you know
eating the whole animal the most
humanely raised animal mostly you know
grass-fed ruminants and getting all of
the organs in the animal and all the
pieces of the animal even you know sort
of sources of calcium resources of fat
like bone marrow to get a full nutrient
profile rather than just eating the
muscle meat which is nutritious but is
gonna lack some things as well yeah so
where do you see where do you see the
problem in in people who adopt a where
do you see problems when you're when
you're dealing with people and people
who'd opted either a diet what comes up
most often so again it comes down to to
a couple of things one probably being
the guts and the other one being
deficiencies or absences of certain
nutrients and again there's there's
particular ways to test for this or you
might just be going from symptomatic
symptomatology and i found that both
have been helpful for me and when i
first came to you guys about three years
ago nourish balanced thrive we went
through a whole bunch of tests that that
really illuminated a lot of problems for
me it was a heavy metal poisoning cuz i
was a pescetarian for nine years I had
no c-diff and the gut and and we had a
bunch of problems we're able to figure
out but I think the symptoms let it or
what led to the testing so quite often
you can you sounds like you can sort of
ascertain what the problem is based on
the symptoms but the tests make it more
clear yeah the more time I spend with
people I think the the less testing I do
because there's you end up with an
overwhelming information and it doesn't
necessarily change what you end up doing
but in reality I think a lot of what you
do can be guided by symptoms so I can
think of two again two world-class
athletes both have been you know in the
same sport both have been world
champions in their sport both went
plant-based at a similar time one
absolutely thrived on it the other one
everything fell apart and I couldn't
even tell you and you know chefs
prepared the best food nutritionists
told them exactly what to do and it
wasn't bad advice by any stretch and I
couldn't even tell you what it was that
caused one to benefit and and the other
to not so sometimes you just have to
iterate and figure out what it is that
that ends up working best for you yeah
yeah so when I'm when I look at both
I've actually tried well I haven't been
I don't try to complete carnivore die
because I've had coffee and maybe some
oils in my diet and it sounds like Paul
would like smack him out of my hand or
something but I can tell you that when I
was much like rich eating the standard
American diet for a long period of time
I was unhealthy I was fat I weighed 80
pounds more than I weigh now my mid-20s
and I just didn't feel very good I went
to a vegan diet for a year and felt
appreciably better
shape-up mostly plant-based diet you
know I'm sure I had some processed foods
in there in my mid-20s but I was
actually eating real foods that my body
wasn't used to or hadn't hadn't
experienced in a very long time and I
felt appreciably better eventually
incorporated fish back into my diet
which led to the high levels of mercury
and in my blood because I also had
issues with with huh it seems unethical
to me to to kill animals although for
the longest so it's the thing I struggle
with the most for the longest time we've
eaten animals but I don't think that is
a good enough reason to say yeah well
we've always done it this way so we have
to keep doing it
the question is what is appropriate for
me as I started working with nourish
balanced thrive I figured out that my
diet was was already pretty dialed in
you all had me actually add meat back
into my diet which was really difficult
for me at first because I I remember
going to like just give me a few cubes
of steak and how awful it was the first
time but of course you you get you get
used to it but also I think a lot of
that for me was was psychological and so
bringing the meat back in into my diet
and over the course of a couple years I
felt better than I ever did
and then last summer I removed
essentially all fiber from from my diet
audio autoimmune paleo and for the first
time in my life I removed inflammation I
didn't realize how inflamed I was until
I got potatoes and rice out of my diet
basically which for most people are
health foods they're good foods I mean
most of us don't look at like oh my gosh
a sweet potato that's terrible for you
but when I when I when I all of a sudden
remove those from my life I felt so much
better and it was unbelievable I better
more energy my autoimmune issues went
away and then I went to Brazil last
September and came back with what I
assumed was a coli and a bunch of other
stuff it tells me that my gut was
probably pretty compromised going down
there in the first place
but for the last seven or eight months
we've been dealing we've been dealing
with AI trying to rebalance my gut at
this point so I guess what I'm saying
here is I've benefited from a
plant-based diet I've benefited
benefited from a mostly carnivorous diet
and I think that Anna where she is right
now is she's she's asking
I'm already 90% of the way there I'm
trying to make these these last few
tweaks what does she need to tweak at
this point I think we have to talk to
her a little bit more in-depth to know
exactly what it is that needs to get
tweaked I mean we don't know her and
like you said you know we don't know
what her value system is so how do we
advise that person I mean we can all
agree like we said earlier that she
should remove the processed foods from
her diet and then after that I think it
would be a process of you know testing
on herself in conjunction with someone
like yourself who can evaluate her
microbiome and her blood markers to
determine you know what's optimal for
her I do think that we can get into this
more if we'd like but in the general
population in the general media there's
been an unfair sort of vilification of
animal foods as well and she kind of
mentioned this in this message that
she's sort of overwhelmed by this this
amount of information and I think from
my perspective one of the greatest
discoveries or realizations that I've
come to is that the demonization of
animal foods is almost entirely
unfounded and I wish people would
appreciate you know how nutrient-dense
these are and how like you sort of
mentioned we've been eating them for our
entire evolution as humans and just
incorporate that into their decisions
regarding how much of them they're going
to eat because I think that people
sometimes demonization do you mean
because I see that from two sides one
for me is like I questioned the ethics
of killing and eating animals that's one
thing the other thing is like I hear you
know Donovan Mitchell of NBA basketball
player he's like yeah I had to stop
eating red meat and you're like that's
probably not why you were unhealthy it
might have had a lot more to do with the
Cheesecake after the meal or something
right yeah and I think this is there are
two issues there that we
talk about individually but I think that
to address the latter issue I think that
if we actually look at the science
around the health benefits of red meat
and you know frankly the the sort of
corresponding media portrayal of red
meat and animal foods as dangerous or
bad for humans when we really dig into
that what we find is that that science
is not doing well it's not actually
accurate and there's no evidence that
red meat is inflammatory or associated
with cancers or any of these things and
so I think that I just hope people could
be exposed to that sort of information
too when they're considering how much of
it they're going to include in their
diets I think that it's been done in a
very large and justice in terms of that
that aspect of its its potential health
benefits and with regard to the ethics I
think that that's a whole separate
conversation you know around you know
how we believe you know our interaction
with ecosystem is yeah well dive into
that we definitely have some questions
about sustainability and ethics if I may
yes I just in terms of the vilification
of animal products as food I mean it has
to be said that animal agriculture is
the second or third largest contributing
greenhouse gas emissions every year we
you know basically slaughter billions of
animals we slit their throats we
electrocute them there is a massive
infrastructure and system around how we
treat and raise animals for food that
goes unseen as a result of AG gag laws
and a lot of you know well-funded
lobbying interest to prevent the
consumers from really understanding the
process of what goes into raising these
animals for our food and I think there
is a real ethical consideration there
and I just know in my own experience
look I grew up you know like I said
standard American diet roast beef you
know the whole deal and when I remove
these products from my diet and of
course this is anecdotal and it's an N
of one thing but I thought well you know
maybe this work maybe it won't and when
I actually felt rejuvenated and then
went on and like competed at a very high
level in you know the world of
ultra-endurance my whole world turned
upside down because I had always been
taught beef is what's for dinner and
milk does a body good you know yeah
yada yada and to feel that good without
those very products that I've been told
my whole life were essential to be
healthy and crucial if you want to
perform as an athlete was really an
eye-opening moment and that opened me up
to the ethical considerations and the
environmental considerations which I
think are very real so if we're gonna
have a conversation about this we have
to you know we have to at least address
that aspect of it here and I'm sure you
know you have plenty of thoughts on that
so I think we can all but I don't know
that we vilified it enough I guess is
what I would say okay I think one thing
that we agree on here is factory farming
bad right I think we're all saying that
to start none of us are saying the
factory farming is a good thing I
correct on this tell me I think
absolutely okay I just make sure you
weren't over there like me yeah lobbying
for big factory farming or something
okay I think the greenhouse gas thing we
should talk about this because I think
this is really interesting and I'm not
sure what sources you're quoting rich
but if you look at the Health
Organization what about the EPA and the
FAO VA and FAO
so if you look at the data released by
the FAO and the EPA there it's broken
down and agriculture itself in the
United States represents about 9% of the
greenhouse gas emissions and that
includes plant and animal agriculture so
we're looking at 91% of emissions
greenhouse gases in the u.s. that are
non agricultural the majority of that
are transportation technology and other
fossil fuel production costs so I would
just sort of respectfully disagree with
the statement that animal agriculture
represents the third largest production
of greenhouse gases in fact if you look
at the data from the FAO and the EPA
animal agriculture represents between
three and four percent of the greenhouse
gases produced in the United States and
plant agriculture is actually more than
that five percents are plants raised to
feed those animals but the plant
agriculture is five to six percent of
the greenhouse gases well I don't want
to get to in the weeds on that I you
know is this Scott Pruitt's EPA it's the
FAO so this is a non-biased United
committee so there was this
unfortunately there was a movie called
cowspiracy that was produced and this is
the live Shaq's livestock's long shadow
and that data was all rescinded and then
recalculated so in that movie they
talked about this large contribution of
greenhouse gasses from animals and they
said oh wait we did the data completely
wrong they didn't look at the lifecycle
greenhouse gas emissions for fossil
fuels and when they redid that is a
non-biased organization this FAO they
found the much more adjusted numbers and
I think worldwide agriculture or
ruminant agriculture is something on the
order of 7 to 8 percent of greenhouse
gas emissions so it's it's quite a small
amount if we eliminated all ruminants
from the face of the earth which would
be an environmental catastrophe we would
decrease the greenhouse gas emissions
the United in the world by 0.3 9 percent
in the United States by 2.6 percent so
it's essentially an non-contributory in
terms of the greenhouse gases then we
couldn't get into the whole lifecycle
and the ecosystem and the way that
ruminants can increase the carbon
carrying capacity of the soil but I
think it's important to just get a sense
of like the the adjustment that's been
made to those greenhouse gas numbers for
a permanence we'll dive more into this
on the maximal up so tell me anything
the real is in here yeah I just wanted
to quickly bring us back to the fact
that there is agreement here and if
large-scale factory farming it does
contribute greenhouse gases that is
something that we should think about if
you are doing grass based truly
sustainable agriculture you can you can
use ruminants to sequester carbon in the
soil so there is a bad way to do it and
that is what we do and everybody agrees
on that and there is a better way to do
it which is potentially beneficial but I
just think that in the bigger picture it
is a good point that I think when you
you want there is an environmental
consideration everybody wants to or the
people here want to have a minimal
impact on the environment
but what you eat is actually quite a
small fraction of I took a plane down
here how many cows are the equivalent of
be flying down to LA to to do this
podcast and one seat I coast-to-coast
flight represents eight months of
driving so we think so if you drive your
car back and forth you
for eight months it's it's functionally
the equivalent of having one seat on an
airplane so we and I say this is someone
who flies a decent amount we go on tour
and stuff and so it is it is one
contributing factor it doesn't mean that
factory farming isn't a contributor no
and you're not trying to belittle that
you know that is an important
consideration right but the you know
there's a bigger picture as well and
there are better bad ways to do it and
that's what we do
largely and there are better ways to do
it if I can bring this back in for an
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
minimalism she talked about values and
we wrote a whole book about how to find
out what your values are and and we we
try to differentiate between the sort of
foundational values and the core values
etc and so and I'm gonna send you a copy
of minimalism if you like our podcast
you'll like the audiobook version of
that or if you want the book book or the
e-book we'll be happy to send those to
you as well as Sean if you could reach
out to her I'd appreciate it let's move
on real quick to our lightning round
this is where a Ryan and I usually
answer questions from social media we're
at the minimalists on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram you can follow these guys
on all the appropriate social media
outlets as well we'll put all of your
handles in the show notes or focus on
will
our first question is from Cory on
patreon do you think most diets are
created to sell books and products it
seems like every diet is backed by
science but that's confusing when one
day I could be a vegan and and the other
could be keto or paleo I think just like
I think many of these diets have like
sort of different Venn diagrams right
and so I you could be a you can be a
keto vegan you can be a keto carnivore
you could be a keto omnivore right and
so like that those are different diets
or yeah and so there's a sort of Venn
diagram here but what do you think
gentlemen oh I have a pithy answer for
you solutions are not about binary in an
analogue world and I think that's quite
often what we're going for here that's
like what is the what's the yes what the
what's the one thing I need to say yes
to as opposed to like what's appropriate
for me so what do you guys think are
most diets created to sell books and
products I don't think so I think that
behind diets are generally people that
are very well-intentioned
and just trying to offer people
solutions I think that in this complex
landscape of health and wellness and
food we're faced with a lot of choices
and I think there's a lot of voices and
I think they're all super valuable and
that's kind of what we're doing here so
I don't think that people are just
trying to sell books or meal plans but I
do think that I am sensitive to the fact
that to the consumer it must look quite
dizzying and yeah hopefully you know we
can try and sort out some of that as a
person who's written four books I can
tell you that it's pretty difficult to
write a book and if you're just doing it
if you're just gonna make up some diet
to write a book that by the way most
your average book on Amazon sells fewer
than one copy so I want you to think
about this for a moment imagine all the
time you put into so it's like point
seven copies or whatever that means you
could even get your mom to buy a copy of
your book a lot of work goes into to
writing a book there are probably better
ways to to make money than by by simply
inventing a diet and writing a book
about it yeah I would agree with that
writing books is hard and it's certainly
not a get-rich-quick scheme and it's
always interesting online we
opportunistic you're cashing in now if
you want to make a really good living
like writing books is probably not the
best avenue to pursue and you know far
be it for me to impugn anyone's you know
intent when they write a book because it
is difficult to do and I would agree
that that you know when somebody sits
down to do that that they are well
intentioned in that regard but you Tommy
got some books on the shelf you you
getting ready to publish I've I think
I've started writing three or four books
and I've never finished it so so exactly
what rich is saying I know how hard it
is and just find the time to actually
you know create something that's that
in-depth is really hard and also a point
seven books yeah I haven't even written
point seven books so um I guess one
thing and again I don't know when you
want to get into this but one thing that
is common across a lot of books a that
they're absolutely trying to help people
and I I believe that the person who is
selling for
for one of a better word a specific
lifestyle has seen true benefit in their
patients or their friends or whoever it
is they worked with and that could be
hopefully spawned based it could be
carnivore they have seen these things
genuinely improve the lives of other
people including themselves and I truly
believe that I don't think any you know
there's very few people who are working
cynically in that way but as well as the
diets I would like to open up the
conversation about the environment so it
like a my environment I mean our
personal lifestyle I mean sleep and
stress and movement and social
connection and you'll find in every diet
book that there's a chapter about that
stuff because I think everybody agrees
that it's super important but you know
the diet is the one thing that makes it
much easier for people to like oh I can
fix my diet you know that's the thing
that everybody wants to get excited
about and change but I believe that much
bigger or improvements can come by
fixing all of that other stuff and I
think that's common across books and
they all influence each other too I mean
I can tell you that as I've changed my
diet for good or bad it is affected
other areas of of my life whether it's
sleep whether it's my ability to
exercise etc and so it sounds like
Richie you you've gotten amazing
benefits athletically from from going to
a plant-based diet I mean yeah I have
you know if I could just you know
respond to that a little bit I mean I
think that human beings are reductive
the scientific method is reductive and
there's an inherent pressure within
publishing to be reductive what is your
hook what's the new thing that you're
trying to pitch here and we all want as
the audience to discover that thing that
is gonna fix us right what is that one
thing if I just do that I'm gonna be
okay
and as I think we can all agree we are
holistic creatures and it's very
complicated
so one diet might work for me is not
going to work for you and if you're
eating the most pristine diet of all
time but you know you can't get along
with your spouse and you're depressed or
you have some other kind of condition or
issue or you're psychologically
imbalanced and you're not sleeping at
night or you're working all the time
you're not a healthy person right so we
have to address all of these things
all fronts there one more question here
from also from patreon come on Twitter
where's all the good questions from
Twitter we've got all the good questions
from patreon this week Arlen says on a
restricted budget like a student or
someone on a low income what would you
recommend as the most important staples
for good nutrition now rich we talked
about this in the last podcast you did
together and you talked about how you
know healthy eating doesn't have to be
you know the $35 smoothie from erawan
yeah I mean particularly plant-based
diets get confused with elitism because
of places like erawan and Whole Foods
and it's very easy to spend a tremendous
amount of money on healthy foods whether
it's carnivore or plant-based but it
doesn't have to be that way certainly
eating whole food plant-based can be
extremely cost effective I mean it's
essentially Popper food I mean I know
you don't eat potatoes but you can buy a
sack of potatoes in a big bag of rice
and you can buy fresh produce locally
from farmers markets or whatever there
is a way to do it on a budget and keep
it simple and with in anybody's range I
want to eat potatoes by the way what was
it like three days ago I had half of a
sweet potato I woke up next more I
thought like I sprained both of my
ankles because I was so inflamed
oxalates my man what and will you say
that I have a friend who ate nothing but
potatoes for an entire year right we
resolved all of his gut issues and what
problems lost all this weight he feel
felt amazing I agree and if Nicodemus
was here he could eat a bag of nails
every day and he would be fine I think
it would help his gut you say oxalates
but um white rice is even worse for me
so if I if I have some white rice and
it's this is a relatively new phenomenon
for me although it's not that new once I
realized that I heard case I know I know
I am but that's the reason I want to
bring all you guys in here because there
are some people out there I mean Tommy
can tell you this or Chris we have a
studio audience of one today
Christopher Kelly is here from nourish
balanced thrive calm as well last time
you guys were on on the pockets there
were a lot of people who came to you and
said hey I'm also I'm struggling and yes
I might be an edge case but there are
more and more and more and more edge
cases now than ever before right so um
actually Paul you want to talk about
that you want to talk about some of the
these edge cases I'm sure you you deal
with well should I respond to that
question about how to do the carnivore
diet or how to budget yeah because I
think it's an interesting point in the
kind of segues into the nose-to-tail
thing as well this idea that like you
know muscle meat is what we've always
prioritized in the West but the organs
of the animal have really unique
beneficial things and I was talking to
someone yesterday and they were saying
you know basically if you walk into a
butcher shop they're throwing organs at
you they'll essentially give you organ
meat from an animal whether it's a liver
or spleen or a pancreas and this offends
our delicate you know westernized taste
but they're quite you know they're quite
nutritious and you know I would ideally
recommend people if they're going to eat
a whole foods animal-based diet that
they eat the organs as well and that can
comprise a large part of your diet and
then you can use the muscle meat to
complement that so I think if you do
that and you're eating liver and you're
eating sort of the trimmings of the
animal the extra fat the collagenous
tissue you're going to get really unique
nutrients there and it's quite
affordable or free in some situations
and you can add to that you know the
best animal meat that you can buy
we're not affordably when I've heard you
talk about nose-to-tail you you mean
that literally you eat the bones a bone
meal right yeah
and I talk about liver jerky which liver
is the one thing I struggle with just
trying to consume its I do desiccated
liver pills right now which is better
than not doing anything I suppose but
I'll eat liver from time to time what's
up with this liver jerky liver jerky you
know it's interesting I think that if as
humans if if we don't eat liver from a
young age we don't developed a taste for
it and it's so different than what we're
used to and it tastes very irony to
people I have tons of friends who are
from different cultures and they've
eaten liver their whole life in those
say it's their favorite food but I never
got liver growing up and so the last
couple of years of eating liver for me
have been toward this gradual
reintroduction and it was one of the
ways that I learned that I could eat the
liver sustainably or in a way that
didn't make me sort of have these sort
of liver trauma experiences and since
then it's gotten to be easier and I can
eat a raw liver now on a daily basis but
there's all these sort of like there's
all these sort of like you know stepping
stones for organ meats for people and
liver turkeys one of those
or the desiccated Oregon tablets from
you know companies like in social
supplements are a great option - yeah so
when you we say nose-to-tail how are you
getting omega-3s are you eating brains
or are you doing or are you doing fish
oil I don't so I don't like fish oil
tablets because of the processing of the
fish oil tablet probably results in
excess oxidation and lipid peroxides
I'll do mostly salmon roe or other fish
roe that's sort of wild and not doesn't
have preservatives and then the bone
marrow and the brain of the animal has
omega 3 2 Omega 3 as well but mostly
right now it's salmon roe and then
there's you know plenty of DHA in egg
yolks as well so all those things the
thing that my pithy answer and I think
Tommy can back me up on this if we
deprioritize a good decision today we'll
pay for our bad decisions later with
interest and I know this from my own my
own health journey yes we we all have to
have a budget but I don't have the money
to spend on something simply when it
comes to food it means it's not the
biggest priority for me and that's
totally fine
but we also need to acknowledge that you
know what sometimes there is a more
budget-friendly way to do it but maybe
the most budget-friendly way is to go
buy that bag of cheetos and and that's
not that that's not going to be that's
not appropriate for anyone really no
matter what we do no matter how we
choose to eat it's such a good decision
when people just think about their diet
intentionally and prioritize it in terms
of their finances I can't think of a
better investment that people can make
than what they're putting in their mouth
yeah and I think we often don't think
about it that way where it is it is an
investment that ends up paying off for
us in really bad ways or really good
ways depending on how we take care of
ourselves and I'm I age 37 and dealing
with a lot of bad things I put into my
body the first 27 years of my life and
I'm I'm really trying to still fix that
so it's it's some of the worth
considering budgeting tell me how do you
talk to people about budgeting when when
they come to you guys a nurse balance
thrive because you know it's
getting help is not always
budget-friendly yeah so nowadays well
it's difficult because I've spent a long
time working with people who have deep
pockets and a lot of means and and
hopefully in the near future I'll spend
more time working with people who don't
and that's where I think the biggest
change needs to happen is that the
average person a doesn't understand how
to do this and then B doesn't know what
to do or can't afford to shop at Whole
Foods say or eat only rib eyes like some
people might do in the carnival of a
carnival carnival movement but I think
both of what these guys have recommended
work really well for somebody who's
trying to go for an omnivorous approach
and potatoes are super cheap rice is
super cheap and that can still be good
quality food and then egg yolks liver
sardines they're all very nutritious and
not necessarily expensive and you can
get a broad range of nutrients from a
wide variety of different foods and it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money but
a bit of it is overcoming some of these
things that that we think we you know
we're just not used to eating like small
fish or liver or learning how to cook
and that's that's a huge problem is that
people don't know how to cook anymore so
I could buy a big bag of potatoes but
rich what do I do with that all right
you know in that that can for some
people be really hard of course you
could just eat raw liver we'd have to
worry about it but but so so it's it's
stuff like that so whatever whatever
approach you take in that sort of being
cognizant and intentional with what we
eat in the food we put in our mouths is
the most important thing and part of
that is learning how to turn whatever
food it is into something to then put
into them out so that cooking is
incredibly important all right gentlemen
we have a bunch more questions here we
have questions about inflammation I want
to dive into that about macro and
micronutrients about the gut biome about
choosing the right supplements about the
most sustainable diet for us and for the
planet and as I mentioned this is sort
of where I struggle like figuring out
the the ethics behind
what we eat the need for protein on a
vegan diet someone asked a question
about that also the need for fiber on a
carnivorous diet selecting the diet
that's right for you as we talked about
all three of you have different diets
and so how do we select the diet that is
appropriate for this individual also
intermittent fasting as well as the
appropriate diet for young children I'm
interested in that because Ella turns
six right now and we feel like we have
her diet
she's turning six this month we feel
like we have her diet sort of dialed in
but I'm interested to hear from y'all
especially from Richard since you have
four kids right okay so we're gonna get
into all of that if you want to listen
to that you can listen this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I or I guess this
week rich Paul and Tommy and I record an
entirely different long-form maximal
episode over on the minimalist private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about topics we don't
usually discuss in public Plus patreon
is the best way for us to fund this
podcast and keep it 100% advertisement
free when you subscribe to the
minimalist private podcast on patreon
you'll receive a personal link so that
our maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also get access
to our entire back catalogue of more
than 100 private podcast episodes find
all the details and all the good stuff
including an additional private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists comm slash support and now
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi this is Katie
from that place Philadelphia I'm calling
in reference to episode I only born 76
when you talk to con right about the on
American Dream and I believe it was Ryan
who is saying he eventually wants to
build a house but totally off the grid
and I believe this information would be
useful for him and any of your listeners
who are interested in the same thing
there is a organization called Earthship
bio tech chure buckhorn in arizona but
there is sections
across the United States and they
specialize in building houses we recycle
material such as tires and plastic
bottles and they are all totally off the
grid environmentally friendly
you guys this is Rachel calling from
Newport Beach California I was calling
you in as a tip for how to responsibly
invest in purchasing a home without
being tied down to a particular study
this is not a concern multiple callers
have discussed recently and I wanted to
share a solution that has worked really
well for my husband at night in Southern
California many homes are at least a
million dollars which would make it
really easy to get in over your head or
not purchase homes using the Dave Ramsey
guidelines for a sensible downpayment
what we have chosen to do instead is
utilize an investment company to
purchase homes out of state in
affordable markets that have been vetted
with a reliable company by purchasing
rental properties in different states
and ensuring we put down a large
percentage we have self a lot of equity
in cash flow through the years this is
an excellent solution for anyone like
myself who lives in an unaffordable
housing market that still wants to
purchase real estate responsibly the
company we've used to purchase their
three properties over the past decade is
Marshall Redick real estate they have
been an amazing resource to us and our
totally honest offering a ton of free
education and training in their website
there are also other companies out there
to do the same thing for us this is how
we've been able to invest in our
family's financial future without making
irrational decisions purchasing a home
in an overpriced market instead of being
a slave to a mortgage we can't justify
or feeling stuck in a certain place we
personally rent and let our home
ownership out-of-state pay for itself
the tenant right I hope this tip helps
some of your callers as a top drive all
right so I want to say thanks again to
rich - Tommy - Paul I would encourage
you to check out them and what they're
doing I want to acknowledge you guys for
doing something meaningful I think what
we're trying to do here all of us is is
help people solve some problems and so
check out rich rich rolls podcast and
everything else all social media rich
roll com
you've got Paul Saladino at Paul
Saladino in decom check out his podcasts
it's the foundational health
I'm sorry fundamental health podcast and
check out his youtube channel as well
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes that's how I first got familiar
with what you're doing Paul and then
Tommy at nourish balanced thrive calm
where he helps people like me all of us
edge cases who are struggling him and
Chris and their whole team over there
they also have the nourish balance
thrive
Podcast gentlemen thank you so much for
being here today it's good to be here
thanks for having me all right y'all
real quick four right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists the minimalist
23 favorite coffee shop so Ryan and I
own a coffee shop down in Saint
Petersburg Florida
I'll give you guys some bags of coffee
not you though Paul I mean I have bowls
yeah we just started roasting what we've
been roasting our own coffee for a while
we just sort of selling it online if you
want to check out the minimalist choice
you can do that at the minimalists not
coffee but also you don't have to limit
your your bean consumption of coffee to
our beans so we just listed our 23
favorite coffee houses around the
country you can find that out at the
minimalists comm /tm see we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
and then yeah I've got some bags of
coffee for you gentlemen
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for a podcast leave a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimus if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week and for
our added value this week let's listen
to another song from this album it's
called good at falling it's a new album
from the Japanese house I know I've
recommended her music before but I just
cannot get enough of this album and
since this conversation today is really
about the confusing landscape of diet
and health and wellness this is a song
that is sort of about confronting
confusion which hopefully we've been
able to do today the line that stands
out to me on this song is can and can
somebody tell me what I want because I
keep changing my mind and I feel like I
feel like that's the thing that we often
get into like when people come to you or
they come to us just tell me what I want
tell me what I need it's not it's not
binary like that anyway here is we talk
all the time from the Japanese house and
if you all leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time and
minimus